one of the most famous women in radio
we're talking about Angela Yee she's a
two-time Gracie Award winner which
honors women in media in 2020 she also
earned a spot in the radio hall of fame
when she was co-host of the popular
Morning Show The Breakfast Club with
Charlemagne tha God and DJ Envy now
she's the host of her own nationally
syndicated radio show let me say that
again nationally syndicated radio show
called way up with Angela Yee the
fast-paced interactive show covers
topics like relationships finance and
entertainment since February in the
launch she's interviewed guests like
jazz singer Samara Joy Shirley Ralph and
John Legend Nick Cannon and Chloe Bailey
Anjali joins us first on CBS Morning hey
how you doing great to have you here I
feel like I'm on The Breakfast Club
right now my Angelic show actually yeah
let's talk a little bit about that more
than a decade waking up early for the
breakfast show how are you getting used
to this new morning routine well not to
make anybody here jealous but I'm loving
it okay I'm getting a lot more sleep I
feel a lot more well rested and I get up
in the morning like and I do things like
the dishes laundry clean up a little I
was always like 20 minutes gotta go when
I was on The Breakfast Club yeah of
course now I can go to the gym no
excuses oh she's waking up early getting
getting it done okay so wait wait up
with Angela Lee and include segments
like shine a light on them and also tell
us a secret so what is your vision for
this show moving forward but like you
said it is very fast paced and that was
the vision for it to have a lot of
segments that were Snippets with a lot
of information you know we have both
Wednesdays it happens once a week where
we give Financial advice and we have
experts come on but it's also fun so I
want to make sure the information is fun
tell us the secret is a really popular
segment where people call in anonymously
and just tell things that they wanted to
it gets real spicy very spicy Colin
that's great
I want to give a shout out to The
Breakfast Club because you were there
for 12 years I loved you and Charlemagne
together and DJ Envy why did you decide
that now was the time you know I had but
on your own I always knew even when I
first started doing The Breakfast Club
that I wanted to eventually have my own
show I came from having my own show as
Sirius and so in my head I was like okay
I'm doing this but I do want to have my
own show and I have my podcast but I've
been talking to I heart about it I
thought I would have to have my own show
and stay on The Breakfast Club which
would have been double duty but in my
head I said I'll do it and then I'll be
able to transition into that and make it
successful but fortunately after the
pandemic they came to me and said Angela
let's just do it do you think Angela
though you stepped on some toes on the
way out the door you did an interview
recently where you said I was the only
woman in the room and I think it led
them to I think it bruised some feelings
and heard some feelings what did you
mean by that uh what I meant was because
it made it sound like that it wasn't a
clean Exeter that it wasn't a good
partnership or did you feel like you got
your toe stepped on you were working
there well I think that for a lot of
women they'll talk about how difficult
it can be when you are the voice of
women and you can't be everything and
sometimes you know you're trying to get
your point across and you can't relate
to somebody I can't relate to what it
would be like to be anybody here and so
I was trying to say not in the whole
company or not on the whole show but in
the actual Studio like if you're in the
kitchen and you're the one woman but
there's you know the hostess and there's
the way there's everybody else right but
in that particular Studio sometimes I'm
like hey guys that's not how it happens
and so that was it but it wasn't meant
as a shot it was just a it was it was
sometimes hard and I think shots fired
because I'm very happy for you as you
know and I love the three of you
together but I also am a big fan of new
chapters yes so not only are you doing
the the podcast she's a businesswoman
just heard that you just closed on a
deal in Detroit oh yes building yes that
was two days ago a 30 unit building
which I'm very excited about in Midtown
Detroit and I actually put together a
group of women of black women to do that
deal and so I wanted Detroit is booming
right now yeah it's a great great
opportunity over here and you have a
coffee company yes what does cup stand
for coffee uplifts people and that
coffee is actually a coffee shop also in
Brooklyn but we do have a brand it's in
you know Whole Foods we're actually
launching in Chelsea Pier starting on
Monday so I'm excited for that and
Target in June
you know you're in the radio hall of
fame you're a legend in that industry
and you still were talking recently
about feeling pressure in this new show
you want to live up so I guess that
history is that what it is I want to
create a new history I never want to
compare myself to something I did
already so I feel like the show is
different and a lot of things I did I
tried to differentiate like even my new
segment is not like a front page
headline news it's more under the radar
stories so I try to bring things that
everybody's not talking about but that I
feel is interesting yeah and so really I
try to do things so it's not like that
it's just different but but you're
different too Angela listen you're a
Brooklyn native your mom is black your
dad is Chinese how did that upbringing
shape who you are today I think that
growing up in New York and in Brooklyn
and with different ethnicities it helps
to be a lot more empathetic to our
people just because I had all these
different cultures that I was dealing
with and I saw a lot of the different
clashes and so for me I feel like in New
York you know when you're here you see a
lot and it takes a lot to shock me so
even doing my podcast and doing my show
you would have to really do something
off the wall for me to be like this is
crazy you got Stone Face most of the
time yeah and you're a lot of crazy
things all the time and I see a lot of
crazy things and I know a lot of crazy
things but are you having a great time
in this new chapter of your life I hope
I am I'm really happy it's nice to
curate my own content and to interview
who I want to interview and you know my
friend Jasmine has been on there with me
since I started and so I've been
enjoying that and you know even having
guests like Dominique Fishback she's
from Brooklyn and I've known her since
way before a swarm and just being able
to say Okay I want this to happen or
different segments that I want that I
know are going to be really exciting
that are working I'm happy about it well
Angela I never bet against you no doubt
about it I call in the chapter I might
call in to tell me a secret yeah all
right well listen it's Anonymous okay
you're just getting started continue to
success report Angela we appreciate it
so you can tune in to weigh up with
Angela Yee weekdays from 10 a.m to 2 p.m
on the iHeartRadio app or on radio
stations around the country